bonsoir et bienvenue ravie de vous
retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce soir
comment échapper au déterminisme social
votre parcours Moussa Camara offre une
excellente réponse merci d'être notre
grand aimant bonsoir à vous bonsoir
terminé c'est votre livre le titre de
votre livre au presse de la cité c'est
l'histoire d'un gamin de Cergy-Pontoise
qui s'en sort peu à peu grâce à la
niaque avant tout mais aussi à l'envie
d'entreprendre votre association
aujourd'hui créer des centaines de
formations pour des jeunes des quartiers
pour créer leur entreprise on va en
parler on est à peu près trois mois
après les violences urbaines votre
regard sur la banlieue nous intéresse on
en parle tout à l'heure mais on commence
ce soir par notre grand débat Macron à
la messe du pape demain à Marseille en
torcel à laïcité ou pas précédent ou pas
un président devrait-il faire ça on en
débat dans un instant avec nos invités
sur ce plateau enfin les parties pris de
nos affranchis ce soir l'humeur de
maître
Rand Perrier le mot de la semaine de
Mariette darrigan et puis une nouvelle
venue nouvelle chronique action planète
avec chaque vendredi Léa Falco voilà
pour le menu on y va Moussa Camara ça
vous regarde c'est parti
ces deux là se connaissent plutôt bien
certains disent même qu'ils se tutoient
le pape François et Emmanuel Macron vont
donc se retrouver à nouveau à Marseille
demain sauf que cette fois le cadre est
bien particulier le président de la
République assistera à la messe papa
géante au Vélodrome mais est-ce vraiment
sa place Raquelle Garrido bonsoir ça
merci d'être là vous êtes député la
France insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis
vous débattez ce soir avec Pierre-Henri
aboyau bonsoir merci à vous d'être là
visage familier de cette émission
philosophe vous présidez le collège de
philosophie bonsoirienne Goz bonsoir
bienvenue éditorialiste et chef de
service politique à France Inter enfin
bonsoir constance Colonna Cesari soit
vous êtes journaliste autrice et
réalisatrice de plusieurs films dont des
documentaires sur le pape le dernier en
date les dernières batailles du pape
François vous pouvez évidemment réagir
mon sac à main c'est un débat
parfaitement citoyen et donc
n'hésitez pas à intervenir interroger
nos invités avant de vous donner la
parole on va revenir un peu sur cette
polémique on plante le décor comme
chaque soir il a 300 secondes c'est le
chrono de Black Ops
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
mon cher Stéphane je vous invite à faire
la même chose le soir à toutes et tous
bonsoir alors cette visite bien pour
connaître qu'aujourd'hui en France
Myriam plus grand monde ne va à la messe
regardez les chiffres dans les années 60
il y avait encore un tiers des Français
qui allaient à la messe tous les
dimanches aujourd'hui sont 3% à y aller
une fois par mois mais attention même si
la main est n’intéresse plus personne en
revanche quand c'est le président de la
République qui décide d'aller assister à
une célébrée par le pape là ça fait
immédiatement la une de l'actualité bon
faut dire que la polémique agite surtout
la classe politique parce que priori les
Français on garde notre Bessa plutôt
normal vous allez voir 70% pardon 65%
trouve que c'est normal que Macron aille
cette messe et puis sur l'autre aspect
est-ce que sa présence brouille le
message du gouvernement sur la défense
ou le respect de la laïcité bien 70% des
Français pensent que non mais bon vous
savez que en matière de laïcité chacun a
son interprétation pour le un public là
la laïcité c'est ce grand principe qui
interdit le port de la baille à l’école
mais qui l'autorise un système alors que
chez les inscrits c'est l'inverse la
grand principe de la laïcité devrait
autoriser le port de la bague à l'école
mais en revanche devrait interdire au
président d'aller à une messe célébrée
par le pape on écoute Jean-Luc Mélenchon
nous sommes une République le président
de la République ni aucun élu n'a sa
place dans une cérémonie religieuse
aucun élu dans une cérémonie religieuse
alors ça c'est peut-être le grand
principe inscrit dans la loi mais avec
la loi il faut tenir compte de la
jurisprudence et en l'occurrence
l'usage veut que depuis le début de la
cinquième république aucun président ne
s'est jamais interdit de participer à
une messe pour une grande occasion pour
vous montrer quelques photos souvenirs
regardez certains sont avec les papes là
c'est de gauche je pense que c'est Paul
chys jusqu'à avec Jean-Paul II Chirac à
la messe tous ils ont été pour une
raison ou pour une autre mais je peux
même dire que ça ne concerne pas que les
pressions de la République regardez en
lors des obsèques de François Mitterrand
qui se sont déroulés à Notre-Dame
célébrée par Monseigneur lucigé on voit
Jospin Mauroy rocker tout le parti
socialiste était présent à cette
cérémonie religieuse donc vous voyez
bien que huguard a tous ses précédents
pour le président Macron c'était
vraiment pas très difficile de justifier
sa présence la messe demain au Vélodrome
on écoute
j'irai par respect et courtoisie et j'y
aurai ma place comme d'ailleurs nombre
de nécessaires on peut y aller je
n'aurai moi-même pas de pratique
religieuses lors de cette messe
mais alors attention n'allez pas
imaginer que en faisant ça Macron est
sûr d'avoir gagné le coup parce que ça
ne présente pas des avantages cette
visite du pape pour lui en effet si le
pape est venu pas en France il a bien
prisé à Marseille c'est pour parler de
la situation des migrants en
Méditerranée sur ce sujet on sait bien
que les positions du pattes sont
beaucoup plus proche de celle de
Mélenchon de celle de Macron d'ailleurs
Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui aime le pape il
avait dit en 2016 c'était le titre qu'il
avait donné un billet sur son blog vive
le pape il expliquait dans le billet que
bah ces positions sur les méfaits du
capitalisme ou sur l'accueil nécessaire
du migrants étaient beaucoup plus proche
de Jean-Paul de François que de
l'exécutif en place alors qui va tirer
le plus de bénéfices de cette visite du
pape à Marseille est-ce que c'est Macron
qui ira à la messe où est-ce que c'est
Mélenchon qui n'ira pas le débat est
ouvert merci pour ce billet
d'introduction Stéphane convaincue ou
pas il y a des précédents
il ne va pas commun notre président et
vous l'avez entendu pas de charistie
ça vous pose un vrai problème moi je
peux constater que le principe de
laïcité il s'érodent il est mal compris
notamment dans la jeunesse
moi j'ai moi-même j'ai des enfants ados
et je constate que par exemple le monde
anglo-saxon tous ces jeunes ils passent
leur journée sur Netflix il va des
émissions ou dans les classes il y a il
y a toutes les religions voilà tout le
monde dans la classe il y a les filles
voilées les garçons avec avec leur
turbansiques ça pose aucun problème et
la le regard on va dire de méfiance qu'à
l'institution scolaire vis-à-vis de la
présence de la religion
ont pris par les jeunes et à côté de ça
vous avez un phénomène ou des élus parce
que la participation aux élections
notamment municipales ces rôdent aussi
ont compris aussi que parfois avoir le
soutien d'un chef commun qui qui
manipule on va dire ou qui maîtrise
quelques voix ça peut changer une
élection donc on a d'un côté des jeunes
qui ne comprennent plus le concept et
qui constate qu'il y a un monde adulte
un monde des autorités alors politique
le sujet c'est ça Emmanuel Macron ils
vont qui vont en fonction de la circo
certains vont se conception certains
vont en faire la le 15 août avec la
Vierge certains vont à recherche Anna
certains vont à leur rupture de du jeûne
voilà à l'Aïd et en fait finalement la
parole publique sur ce qu'est la laïcité
ce père et ce qu'elle aille cité il faut
quand même le rappeler c'est la
séparation c'est la séparation de deux
espaces un espace public dans lequel on
fait de la politique et qui doit être
dépourvu de dogme religieux et un espace
privé au sens de ce que nous sommes dans
notre vie privée et où effectivement il
faut une liberté de conscience totale et
la liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire
et donc il y a entorse pour vous mais
totalement
c'est que le président de la République
il fait comme il fait comme un maire il
fait du clientélisme il voit qu'il y a
une super animaux qui vient au Vélodrome
et il se dit pourquoi j'irai pas à côté
de la il vient il vient voler un peu du
feu de cette super star et le problème
c'est que ça rend la vie compliquée à
ceux qui authentiquement veulent faire
vivre la laïcité dans un message où nous
comme autorité et branche de l'État
parce que la séparation de l'Église et
de l'État implique de définir c'est
qu'il est tard moi je considère que les
élus nous sommes un minimum
nous a tricoter la neutralité relique
séparation pierrotavoyo on regarde la
loi 1905 et de la laïcité qui la conçoit
est-ce que vous partagez la position de
la qualité parce que si on se pose la
question de savoir quel est le contraire
de la laïcité c'est pas la religion
c'est pas du tout la religion cité
permet justement la cohabitation des
religions au contraire non non mais
justement le contraire de la laïcité
c'est le fondamentalisme c'est à dire la
prétention d'une doctrine séparation
vous pensez que c'est une fusion je peux
terminer c'est le
fondamentalisme la fondamentaliste et la
prétention de tout régenter et donc dans
cette perspective le fait d'aller à une
cérémonie religieuse ça ne remet pas du
tout en cause la séparation pourquoi
parce que il n'y va pas ou les
présidents quand ils vont dans une
cérémonie ils vont pas en tant que
croyant en tant que soumis ils y vont
comme participants à la vie politique et
ont considérant qu'on peut respecter
effectivement des communautés il y a du
clientélisme ça je vous l'accorde mais
je veux dire votre partie à l'égard du
vote musulman fait aussi du clientélisme
un seul exemple moi je suis élu de les
incendie
les pieds dans un lieu jamais en tant
que restons sur la laïcité et le pape
juste voyez il y a d'autres précédents
quand François Hollande après les
attentats va dans une synagogue il porte
une kippa quand on visite une mosquée on
enlève ses chaussures ce sont des signes
de dévotion ce sont des marques de
respect là il s'agissait pour l'hyper
cacher d'une cérémonie avec les morts
très régulièrement les chefs d'État vont
dans des lieux de culte quand il y a des
catastrophes qui sont aussi nationales
là c'est une messe on est dans une dans
un cadre purement religieux moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord on peut sur le plan
politique considérer que c'est pas
opportant mais pas au nom du principe de
la laïcité parce que si c'était au nom
du principe de la laïcité toutes les
présences de président dans quelques
cérémonies religieuses que ce soit à
l'occasion des catastrophes seraient
illicites donc non
on est en 1918 le nombre de millions de
morts millions de morts de la Première
Guerre mondiale qui est une boucherie il
y a au nom pour tous ces millions de
morts en Notre-Dame une cérémonie et
Clémenceau vous voyez vous allez c'est
pas un duel hein
effectivement il y avait une dimension
une dimension fondamentaliste dans
l'Église catholique oui bien sûr il y
avait une prétention alors après c'est
aujourd'hui l'Église catholique n'a plus
cette prétention d'ailleurs de ce point
de vue là vous voyez le désaccord est
pas tant entre sur les politiques donc
le contexte a très largement changé le
fondamentalisme aujourd'hui ne se situe
pas du côté de l'église catholique il se
situe ailleurs il est présent donc oui
la différence entre certaines religions
égard à l'application
entre le fondamentalisme et la religion
très différent c'est ça le débat il est
tranché et c'est très net et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'on vous a invités parce
que vous n'êtes pas d'accord et ce qui
nous regarde
le mot culte dans la loi de 1905 la loi
ne reconnaît ni une fonctionne aucun
culte donc il fait pas la différence
aux observations sur le degré
d'intensité
c'est pas parce que vous êtes pas
d'accord que vous avez monopoliser la
parole c'est moi qui l'a distribue il y
a le gode j'ai trouvé une troisième voie
alors entre déjà
la décision il n'y a pas d'Emmanuel
Macron à la laïcité dans cette démarche
pour deux raisons le Conseil d'État
distingue l'agent public qui doit
respecter cette neutralité absolue de
l'élu qui a une liberté un principe de
liberté qui préside pour l'élu l'élu
l'agent public c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose et deuxième chose là où
l'Elysée s'en sort quelque part dans
cette polémique et cette s'en sortir en
tout cas c'est qu'il y a le chef
temporel du Vatican le chef d'État
politique et représentant d'un état de
Vatican comme Emmanuel Macron présente
la France et le chef spirituel des
catholiques et Macron il dit quoi il dit
bah moi je vais voir mon alter ego chef
d'État mais donc qui l'écoutera alors
c'est là c'est là où l'ambiguïté arrive
c'est que il y a le citoyen Macron qui
on s'est assez comment dire à une
relation très particulière à la religion
c'est conseillé disent de lui qu'il est
un sorte de de de mystique agnostique et
mystique en même temps spiritualiste
agnostique voilà ça l'expression qui
revient à 12 ans il se fait baptiser on
va y revenir son parcours le collège des
Jésuites etc donc c'est là où il est à
la Providence à Amiens et donc il est
très imprégné de ce rapport à leur
religion moi ce qui m'interroge le plus
c'est alors fait-il de la politique ou
pas c'est l'accumulation de signaux en
quelques semaines de signaux envers les
catholiques de France vous avez la
semaine dernière un une collecte qui a
été lancé un loto du patrimoine
religieux pour sauver entre 2500 et 5000
églises qui sont en périls à travers la
France des petites églises les communes
n'ont plus les moyens forcément de de de
les financer de les rénover des toitures
etc il y a eu ça il y a 10 jours avant
ça on en parlait on parle refaire le
débat mais la Baya qui est aussi un
signal de dire
ça ça vise plus les musulmans qu'une
autre religion donc vous avez une
accumulation de signaux et plusieurs
fois depuis 6 ans Emmanuel Macron a
montré bah son empathie il a même failli
un jour à la messe d'hommage à Johnny à
La Madeleine sortir le goupillon et puis
c'est au dernier moment et non non je
vais pas faire le signe parce que je
suis le chef d'État et voilà c'est ça à
fleur c'est c'est
toujours là et parfois on ne sait pas
quelle est la part de comment dire de de
recherche d'une relation politique à une
certaine France dont il a besoin aussi
de ne pas se couper il y a tout ça qui
est en jeu refaire sortir tout ça vous
voulez vous montrer ce sont un peu plus
tard mais puisque vous en parlez il y a
le Goose quel est le rapport précis
d'Emmanuel Macron à la laïcité on l'a vu
par exemple je vais vous montrer c'était
lors de sa première visite
pratiquant c'était un an après son
élection en 2018 il reçoit le titre de
chanoine de Latran c'est son droit
François Hollande ne l'avait pas fait et
regarder en la basilique
saint-jean-de-la-trans à Rome donc la
cérémonie religieuse avec les yeux au
ciel les époux les époux Macron Brigitte
qui on le voit est imprégnée par par
cette cérémonie et c'est vrai cette
question dans des images comme ça du
rapport à la laïcité c'est un droit de
prendre ce titre on va entendre aussi
d'autres discours plus tard sur la
question d'un lien abimé entre l'État et
l'Église c'était dans un autre discours
quel est ce rapport qu'il a ce président
là on a vu ça par exemple Nicolas
Sarkozy il avait fait également c'est
pas une obligation chaque chef d'État
interprète sa relation avec l'Église
catholique et non pas là le Saint Siège
c'est différent moi je crois
contrairement aux voix qui se sont
exprimées contrairement à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais contrairement aussi à la
réponse qu'a apporté Emmanuel Macron
lui-même à cette polémique que justement
c'est une autre interprétation de la
laïcité qu'il faut invoquer là c'est à
dire que la garantie de neutralité de
liberté absolue à chaque citoyen de
vivre sa foi son cul d'aller ou non à
l'église à la synagogue à la mosquée
c'est finalement une liberté qui est
autorisée aux citoyens Emmanuel Macron
lui-même donc
la polémique les chefs d'État mais pas
du tout il est aussi
la fonction de chef d'État ne lui enlève
pas ses droits de citoyen et à mon avis
il a eu tort de répondre que c'est en
tant que chef d'État qu'il y allait
c'est tentant que citoyen qu'il a le
droit d'être là d'autant qu'il prend un
risque politique important ça c'est
autre chose parce que là si dans son
entretien avec le pape ou même si le
message lors de l'office religieux à la
messe est vraiment un message d'accueil
de solidarité d'humanité il risque d'y
avoir un contraste avec
Macron alors là entre le Saint Siège et
la France sur des questions politiques
pas seulement l'immigration l'accueil
des migrants mais aussi la détention des
harmones nucléaires puisque le Vatican a
signé le tian le fameux traité
interdisant la détention même des
harmones nucléaires sur la question
économique sur l'inégalité sur la
question bien sûr du suicide assisté
donc il y a de toute façon
Emmanuel Macron veut faire la photo avec
le Pape François c'est clair comme
beaucoup de chefs d'État de la planète
il le fera mais c'est en effet assez
dépend pour bien comprendre se faire
il tape l'incruste c'est vrai ou pas non
il s'est invité c'était pas programmé
j'ose la comparaison la finale perdue au
tir au but à Moscou par Moscou
Saint-Pétersbourg je sais plus le final
du Mondial bref quand il va sur le
terrain chercher à douber mettre la main
faire le geste quasi religieux sur
Kylian Mbappe en disant que tu as perdu
mais tu es brillant tu es beau tu es
fort au Qatar parce que je dis ouais
il recherche l'image il cherche
l'événement pour se coller à l'image
l'incruste je laisse à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon la paternité de cette
expression mais évidemment qu'il va il
va chercher la photo c'est la fête
donc la quatrième fois en 6 ans qui est
un président de la République française
va voir le pape en tête-à-tête c'est
c'est jamais arrivé donc c'est vraiment
une recherche de proximité à double
tranchant parce que plus il cherche la
photo voir le tutoiement il y a un débat
pour savoir si la maman tutoyer c'est
pas sûr plus il cherche la photo
tu cherches la photo de la proximité et
plus cela agace aussi le Vatican parce
que Vatican on n'est pas d'accord sur
plein de choses on peut lister tous les
sujets la loi séparatiste la France la
PMA pour toutes la fin de vie on en
parle on en reparlera la fermeture des
églises pendant la pandémie donc quelque
part c'est un espèce de de baiser à
double tranchant pour les deux et est-ce
qu'on disait sur la recherche de
l'événement effectivement Emmanuel
Macron a besoin il se dit là il y a le
vélodrome il y a le défilé sur le Prado
ce sont des moments tout comme tout
comme Charles III il a besoin à chaque
fois de se régénérer aussi en popularité
à travers des événements marquants de
son côté le pape François son il ne
vient pas en France il vient à Marseille
en Provence voilà ça il l'a dit porte de
la Méditerranée pourquoi pas pourquoi il
dit ça c'est la franchise du pape
François il a commencé à l'emper 12a en
2013 c'est pas un hasard l'Empire à
l'époque on disait c'est une prophétie
parce que c'est 2 ans avant la fameuse
crise des migrants quand même il va là
c'est son premier choix de voyage parce
qu'avant il était allé à Rio mais Rio
c'était les JMJ donc c'était un agenda
de son du prédécesseur il va à Lampedusa
il fait le tour comme ça du bassin
méditerranéen que dans des petits pays
des périphéries il détestent finalement
les capitales arrogantes riches et
notamment les places européennes il va
pas à Bruxelles il va pas mardi il va
pas Londres il va pas à Paris non il a
des choix qui sont ces objectifs cette
espèce de croisade qu'il a lancé en se
disant l'injustice aujourd'hui la vraie
tragédie c'est cette Méditerranée qui
est devenue un grand cimetière donc
protocole très depuis 10 jours on vit là
dessus sur comment comment Macron a
cherché à multiplier les rendez-vous
privilégiés avec le pape qui au départ
ne voulait aller que aux rencontres
méditerranéennes avec les 65 c'est la
réussite fait cardinal oui dernière qui
obtient ce cadeau suprême voilà de faire
venir le pape d'inscrire Marseille dans
cette événement des rencontres
méditerranéennes qui ont eu lieu à Barry
à Florence dans les années précédentes
et qui réussit en plus à garder le pape
deux jours
à Marseille pas en France Emmanuel
Macron lui dit tant que tu viens en
France pas à Marseille il lui a même
proposé de venir à Paris de faire une
petite étape à Paris il y a tout essayé
il y avait proposé lors d'une conférence
zoom un peu pathétique au téléphone
filmé où il disait Emmanuel Macron
disait au pape mais venez Saint Père et
le pape lui répond les froidement mais
vous savez que c'est la pandémie qu'on
ne peut pas voyager
on a pu lire certaines tribunes des
grandes historiens Jean-Noël Jannet dans
le monde dire attention il pourrait y
avoir le sentiment d'une inégalité de
traitement d'une forme d'injustice à
l'égard des musulmans il les citait à
avoir comme ça le président dans cette
grande cérémonie papale au Vélodrome là
où il se fait c'est vrai plus discret et
d'autres voilà la citation je vous
laisse la découvrir sentiment d'une
insupportable inégalité de traitement
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez moi ce que
moi j'ai écouté les débats les avis je
partage moi je suis comme la plupart des
Français sur le sondage moi cette visite
me choque pas du tout pour la simple
bonne raison que
il a dit qu'il est allé en tant que chef
d'État mais en terme en tant que chef
d'État ou en tant que citoyen c'est
l'avenue du Pape le pape pour moi c'est
c'est depuis tout petit je suis pas de
confession c'est la même confession que
je parle mais c'est le pape c'est pour
nous c'est un personnage mondial et
international après c'est vrai que par
rapport au débat autour de laïcité on y
comprend plus rien du débat de la
société beaucoup de jeunes vous leur
posez la question de ce que c'est la
laïcité ils savent pas du tout c'est des
débats pour nous de plateau télé
politique mais en vrai il faut revenir à
cette pédagogie il a excité c'est pour
moi c'était un beau projet mais
aujourd'hui c'est un terme qui est
devenu très politique ou parfois on peut
utiliser cette laïcité pour montrer du
doigt certaines religions pour dire que
ils ne sont pas dans les clous de de la
République etc et du coup c'est là où il
y a un vrai travail à faire
d'explication de sensibilisation de
poser les choses parce qu'aujourd'hui on
sait que les débats autour de la laïcité
dans la société dans laquelle on est
c'est des débats clivant comment on
arrive à retrouver un sujet d'apaisement
autour de la cité parce que la lycée
c'est ce qui nous permet tous d'être
ensemble moi je le vois dans tout ce que
je fais quand à travers toute la France
on a des gens qui viennent de partout
quoi avec de toute origine de toute
religion et on se demande pas qui sont
on se demande qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
faire avec nous est-ce qu'il y a un
échec de la pédagogie de la
compréhension même on est dans une
situation et le débat qu'on a eu tout à
l'heure vigoureux mais le reflète c'est
qu'on en fait il y a deux conceptions
laïcité qui s'affrontent il y a une
conséquence de type un peu anglo-saxon
une conception française pour le dire
d'une image
elle m'est venue quand il y avait un
étudiant texan qui me posait la question
l'idée du du Salou de m'est venu il y a
deux types de saloon dans le l'Ouest
américain il y a les saloon ou c'est
écrit veuillez enlever
ôter votre Colt quand vous rentrez dans
le saloon puis il y a 2e saloon où on
dit vous pouvez rentrer dans le salon
avec votre colte mais sachez que tout le
monde a un colt bien c'est exactement
les deux modèles
vous remplissez Colt par religion on
peut rentrer avec la religion dans
l'espace public parce que tout le monde
a une religion et c'est une logique
alors c'est bizarre vous la défendiez
mais c'est une logique un peu un peu
néolibéral
où on laisse le col dehors je crois pas
parce que c'est les jeunes que vous
dites
votre discours à vous sur le relativisme
et le défense là
finalement ça soit la vision ou de tout
le monde on peut pas opposer la question
de l'école et Macron à la messe deux
choses très différentes enlever la Baïa
quand vous rentrez à l'école c'est pas
la position
donc est-ce qu'on rentre dans l'espace
public avec sa religion ou est-ce qu'on
a fait ça l'entrée
moi je suis
sûr que le
ici dans cet espace là il a absolument
le droit d'exercer sa religion c'est la
liberté de cul c'est la liberté de
conscience il est citoyen il a le droit
à ça ici il est dans son lieu de travail
la fonction publique il n'a pas le droit
c'est ça qui est la même chose qui
s'applique absolument moi à Emmanuel
Macron c'est pourquoi il avait peut-être
le droit d'aller à cette messe en tant
que simple citoyen là-dessus je serai
plutôt d'accord avec vous mais il
s'engage comme chef de l'État vous dites
on a compris
il a un problème vous répondez là-dessus
sur les différentes sphères il y a pas
de sphères mais trois selon allez-y fait
trois sphères c'est là où il y a une
différence il y a la sphère privée oui
liberté il y a la sphère publique
neutralité et puis il y a une autre
sphère la sphère civile c'est la rue le
travail et dans cette sphère il y a un
principe c'est pas un principe juridique
c'est le principe de la discrétion on
respecte on s'efface pas de manière
excessive
non je suis en train de vous dire c'est
pas du droit c'est du vivre ensemble
c'est du vivre en commun non c'est pas
une règle pour le faire non j'ai pas une
règle vous parlez de règles juridique la
laïcité ce n'est pas la discrétion
de vivre c'est passionnant parce que ça
montre à quel point voilà la
compréhension l'acception de la laïcité
la lettre et l'esprit de la loi peuvent
être parfois un peu éloignées je
voudrais qu'on revienne à Emmanuel
Macron est-il un fervent laïque par
exemple quand il dit ça et là je vous
rappelle un petit peu le discours des
Bernardins devant les évêques de France
c'était il y a quelques années écoutez
est-ce qu'il est vraiment laïque quand
il dit ça
pour nous retrouver ici ce soir
Monseigneur nous avons sans doute vous
et moi bravé les sceptiques de chaque
bord
et si nous l'avons fait c'est sans doute
que nous partageons confusément le
sentiment que le lien entre l'Église et
l'État s'est abîmé et qu'il nous importe
à vous comme à moi de le réparer
la réparation d'un lien abîmé attention
la séparation c'est là l'église d'une
église c'est pas de toutes les Églises
catholique absolument
on est dans cette ambiguïté continue qui
à mon sens est moins une question je
vous disais de de laïcité pure que de
recherche d'un lien avec une France qui
décroche politiquement de celle que lui
a voulu incarner régulièrement il y a
des piqûres de rappel il ne veut pas
s'éloigner de cette France là quand il
quand il parle à leurs actuelles
d'immigration c'est évidemment un signal
envoyé certains diront une triangulation
politique pour aller chercher un
électorat qui s'éloigne mais il y a
vraiment ça et dans son entourage à
l'Élysée il y a beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent avec eux de la politique
mais on voit à quel point ça peut être
non il ne fait pas que de la politique
il y a dans ce discours
on lance de citoyens mystique qui
s'expriment aussi bien sûr qu'il y a ça
je vous disais ce moment ce geste volé
enfin ce geste arrêter au dernier moment
le goupillon chez la messe de Johnny là
effectivement tout était dit dans ce
moment dans ce geste raté vous verrez
qu'on revoit un moment donné c'est
hésitation qui disait beaucoup de choses
d'Emmanuel Macron et aussi qui accentue
le contraste avec ses prédécesseurs
notamment avec François Hollande qui lui
n'en avait strictement rien à faire ce
débat à quel point ce concept de laïcité
ce principe constitutionnel de laïcité
difficilement partagée compris est-ce
que vous trouvez que le chef de l'État
participe à la clarification là en
allant à la messe au Vélodrome depuis le
début est-ce que est-ce que sur la
question
faudrait il faut relativiser mais sur le
coin écoulé avec des événements
au patrimoine
religieux en France ça s'appelle les
chantiers cardinal c'est une vieille
tradition la France entretient les
églises
en trois semaines des signaux
pour garantir la préservation de ce
patrimoine qui fait notre culture il y
aurait plus d'églises en France et on ne
déplorerait donc là il fait son boulot
de chef de l'État quand il parle au
Bernardin là on sent que c'est plus
personnel et qu'en effet on peut pas la
laïcité c'est pas le refus de relation
entre l'Église et l'État elles ont des
relations les églises avec notre état et
en effet bon c'est son interprétation
abîmée parce qu'il reconnaît dans ce
discours qui est assez intéressant la
place des associations catholiques
passent simplement de la hiérarchie pas
simplement du clergé pas simplement des
fidèles mais toutes ces structures qui
mettent la main à la pâte comme à
l'intérieur qui font plein de choses sur
le terrain c'est vrai à Marseille dans
des dialogues interrompu avec une
hypertrudence sur l'école privée vous
avez vu le renoncement papel Ndiaye n'a
pas réussi Emmanuel prend l'a pas
soutenu à créer davantage de mixité
scolaire dans les écoles privées parce
qu'en échange de des fonds publics qui
alimentent les écoles privées
catholiques il n'a pas réussi enfin il
n'a pas voulu rentrer dans ce combat
scolaire là à nouveau il y a les
résistance
en tout cas c'est passionnant parce
qu'on voit bien que voilà je le
décryptage d'Emmanuel Macron est un est
un sport en soi on va on va s'intéresser
à la figure de François à présent 10 ans
de pontificat déjà avec clairement des
des prises de position on l'a bien dit
très très politique sur les migrants le
climat les inégalités progressistes
voire gauchistes François c'est un sujet
de Marion Becker regardez
en pleine crise migratoire cette visite
papale et celle d'un pape politique
défendre les migrants est une cause
qu'il porte depuis son intronisation il
y a 10 ans avec une parole engagée
fraîchement élue il se rend déjà très
vite à Lampedusa aux chevets des
migrants africains pour défendre leur
cause
mais aussi pour réveiller les
consciences
pour que cela ne se reproduise plus
jamais s'il répète
dès lors il se rendra régulièrement au
chevet des migrants au Mexique à la
frontière américaine à Lesbos en Grèce
il appelle inlassablement les dirigeants
à accueillir les réfugiés c'est la
pierre angulaire de son pontificat le
pape c'est également engagé sur
l'écologie pour défendre la planète en
2015 il publie le laodat aussi une
encyclique pour alerter sur les causes
humaines du changement climatique une
première pour l'église
on ne sort pas d'une crise de la même
manière on en sort meilleur ou pire
c'est le défi et si nous n'en sortons
pas meilleur nous sommes sur la voie de
l'autodestruction François
c'est aussi le pape qui revendique la
modestie et a remis l'église au service
des pauvres il reste cependant
conservateur sur le plan doctrinal sur
les questions familiales et éthiques
liées à la vie il est ouvertement opposé
à l'euthanasie et au suicide assisté
je constate que il y a de quoi
entretenir un dialogue diplomatique et
politique avec ce pape c'est quand même
très intéressant un pape latino
américain argentin qui trouve une source
quand même de la théologie de la
libération le parti pris des pauvres qui
renoue s'agissant des
Renoux toutes les toutes les religions
sont matricées par le principe
d'hospitalité l'hospitalité est un
principe fondamental dans absolument
toutes les philosophies humaines et dans
toutes les religions et ce qui est
frappant de constaté c'est à quel point
les régimes juridiques les gouvernements
quand ils ne veulent plus mettre en
oeuvre ce principe
philosophique des théologique sont
obligés de faire des lois pour
criminaliser l'accueil vous prenez
l'Italie il y a le maire de riaccio
mimolucano qui avait organisé enfin qui
ont les gens étaient échoués sur les
plages de sa commune en Calabre donc il
les a accueillis les amis au boulot etc
ça a été un modèle économique qui a fait
renaître son village rural mais il a été
puni par la loi italienne condamnée à 10
ans de prison il est encore la peine
donc politiquement il faudrait que la
voix du pape ça porte bien sûr le débat
public mais bien sûr vous la député en
fait spontanément les gens ont
l'hospitalité comme comme matrice il
faut tout une société il faut une
injonction pour réduire l'hospitalité et
finalement de ce point de vue c'est pas
spécialement le pape de l'atelier
américain de la théologie de la
libération là sur l'immigration sur
l'immigration c'est quelque chose de à
mon sens beaucoup plus profond que l'on
entend et qui est aussi un attachement à
la vie c'est vrai que la Méditerranée
est un cimetière et que et que même
désormais on appelle nécropolitique la
façon que à l'Union européenne de gérer
l'immigration ou plutôt de gérer
l'accueil en fait la crise que nous
vivons n'est pas fondamentalement une
crise de l'immigration mais une crise de
l'accueil on a besoin de tarir les
raisons pour lesquelles les gens fuient
leur pays c'est jamais agréable de fuir
leur son pays on a tous envie de vivre
dans son propre pays quand ce n'est pas
le cas il faut savoir accueillir
dignement bon c'est intéressant quand
même c'est ces échos entre entre le pape
et la France insoumise vive le pape dit
des Jean-Luc Mélenchon je suis fascinée
de voir à quel point ce pape hystérisent
des plus Clerico des politiques français
reconquêtes rassemblement national il
exaspère Marion maréchal il insupporte
Eric Zemmour Zemmour invente même des
citations qui n'existent pas de
Saint-Augustin et on ne peut pas faire
le bien jusqu'au mal bon personne n'a
jamais retrouvé cette citation de
Saint-Augustin pour dire que le pape
François est beaucoup trop politique et
fait du tort aux Européens à force de
vouloir ouvrir les frontières et et
promouvoir l'asile voilà donc ça c'est
ça c'est assez fascinant de voir que le
spectre politique français le plus
traditionaliste finalement est en guerre
politique
participer à l'agenda du pape participer
à un moment de recueillement avec le
Pape près de Notre-Dame de la Garde
Bonne-Mère à Marseille une stèle qui est
qui est dressée
en hommage aux disparu en mer marin
émigrants et puis finalement non on ne
se mélange pas il y aura une cérémonie à
part et laïque des insoumis ailleurs
dans Marseille dans un lieu un ancien
McDo reconverti dans un restaurant
solidaire ou travail aussi d'anciens
migrants et des personnes qui qui
cherchent des papiers le mot de la fin
constance Colonna c'est vrai que ce pape
voilà qui vont se souvient de crucifix
avec le gilet de sauvetage il va avoir
des messages c'est sûr sur sur les
migrants en même temps dire qu'il est
progressiste quand on entend aussi son
sa position sur la fin de vie quand on
entend que le texte a été même reporté
après sa visite c'est un peu trop
baignablement progressiste on va pas lui
demander d'être pour l'avortement d'être
pour le suicide assisté donc là
évidemment c'est la parole de l'église
il a déjà si vous voulez arrêter cette
obsession du message à caractère sexuel
on se souvient de Jean-Paul II avec les
préservatifs à random en 91 ans en
Pologne donc c'est un pape qui à
d'autres combats et notamment ses
combats sont sociaux et politiques et il
dit à l'Europe au lieu de lui dire il
faut arrêter les valeurs non négociables
c'est pas son message il lui dit à
l'Europe
l'injustice le drame la tragédie de
notre époque c'est la migration merci
aussi on s'arrête là peut-être un nouvel
encyclique sur le climat on va s'arrêter
là merci beaucoup c'était passionnant
voilà qui a dit que la question papa et
la question politique était s'éloignée
vraiment pas revenez quand vous voulez
vous restez avec moi moussaka Mara dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties pris
de nos affranchis ce soir l'humeur de
Bertrand Perrier oui il faut harceler
les harceleurs le mot de la semaine de
Mariette darrigran ça fait quoi ce qu'on
vient de dire c'est immigrationniste et
puis une nouvelle chronique et une
nouvelle chroniqueuse pour action
planète bonsoir Léa Falco de quoi nous
parlez-vous ce soir bonsoir ce soir on
parle d'adaptation des conditions de
travail au réchauffement climatique à
tout de suite les amis mais d'abord on
va plonger dans dans votre livre et dans
votre parcours on est trois mois après
les émeutes ça m'intéresse de vous
entendre sur ce qui s'est passé parce
que votre livre fait du bien déterminez
comment on s'en sort au prince de la
cité vous racontez à la fois votre
parcours et votre envie d'entreprendre
regarder c'est dans l'invitation
d'Hélène Bonduelle et on en parle juste
après
si on vous invite mon sac Camara c'est
parce que vous refusez l'assignation à
résidence le déterminisme social vous
l'enfant des quartiers de Cergy-Pontoise
avaient très tôt compris que la solution
ne viendrait pas d'en haut que seul le
travail payerait le droit à la paresse
très peu pour vous moi je savais que
finalement en étant plus jeune ma vie à
la lettre comme celle de mes grands
frères on va dire entre guillemets pas
avec un perspective d'évolution de
carrière professionnelle et en fait j'ai
réussi à déjouer tout ça le jour où j'ai
monté ma première entreprise à 20 ans
c'était une manière de lutter contre le
déterminisme social d'être déterminé
votre réussite passera donc par
l'entrepreneuriat et vous en faites
votre mantra c'est ce parcours que vous
racontez dans votre livre déterminé la
seule voie d'excellence possible ne peut
pas être dites-vous seulement Zidane ou
Jamel Debbouze pourquoi n'y aurait-il
pas aussi des entrepreneur c'est pour en
finir avec ses clichés que vous créez
les déterminer en 2015 un programme de
formation intensif de 6 mois pour des
entrepreneurs en devenir et surtout un
réseau investir sur vous c'est investir
sur l'avenir c'est investir sur la
jeunesse et ça c'est important créer des
ponts entre les quartiers le monde de
l'entreprise voilà la solution un patron
n'est pas un diable dites-vous et vous
ne vous y êtes pas trompé dès le début
c'est le patron du Medef qui croit en
vous c'est une sortie par le haut des
quartiers des régions de la France par
l'économie par l'entreprise plus on aura
d'entrepreneurs plus on aura d'emploi
créé depuis vous inspirez aussi les
politiques vous intégrez un groupe de
travail sur l'industrie verte à Bercy
vous étiez aussi présent aux journées
parlementaires de renaissance
trois mois après les émeutes
moussakamura la colère des quartiers a
éclaté à la face du pays alors nous
avons une question pour vous croyez-vous
vraiment qu'il suffisent d'être
déterminé pour s'en sortir
réponse ça suffit vraiment je pense que
la détermination c'est un moteur et la
détermination vous permet de rencontrer
des bonnes personnes de créer ces
opportunités il suffit pas que de la
détermination moi je le dis dans mon
parcours
c'est le fruit de rencontre mais ces
rencontres je les ai provoqué par le
travail parce que j'avais envie et même
quand tout me laissait penser que
c'était pas possible finalement je me
suis battu et c'est détermination le
fait que j'avais pas de diplôme que je
connaissais personne mes parents étaient
pas entrepreneurs donc
il y a pas vraiment de colère il y a pas
vraiment de ressentiment il faut quand
même rappeler votre parcours vos parents
viennent du Mali c'est ça famille de
huit enfants un père balayeur une mère
femme de ménage qui travaille très tôt
le matin dans les bureaux qui oblige de
repartir après le dîner familial le soir
à nouveau travailler vous auriez pu être
nourri par une forme de quelque chose de
violent et c'est pas du tout le cas
c'est quoi cette détermination qui n'est
pas au fond une sorte de rage en fait la
rage amène à rien moi mes parents ils
m'ont éduqué comme comme quoi il fallait
beaucoup travailler et que la situation
dans laquelle on était bah si vous
travaillez beaucoup bah finalement vous
pourrez peut-être vous en sortir et ça a
été aussi l'éducation de ce que j'ai
reçu autour de moi c'est des pères de
famille ça a été l'école je le dis dans
mon livre c'est une bouée de sauvetage
parce que le fait de d'être à l'école
d'apprendre des choses moi quand je
rentrais pour faire mes devoirs mes
parents ils parlaient pas la langue très
bien donc les personnes pouvaient
m'aider changer d'école aussi avec un
peu plus de mixité exactement j'ai
changé d'école c'était pour moi c'était
un mal pour un bien parce que ça m'a
permis aussi de découvrir aussi un autre
écosystème et là j'ai fait des
découvertes incroyables parce que c'est
ça et la détermination pour revenir moi
je l'utilise comme un état d'esprit
c'est un moteur pour moi c'est pas une
fin en soi s'il y a pas les
détermination si elle a détermination
sans le travail ça marche pas alors
cinquième de la famille
pourquoi parce que déjà le le plus grand
du quartier entre guillemets qui nous
avait accompagné dans le chantier il
était plus là du coup finalement lui
l'engagement qu'il avait il avait eu
plutôt eu avec ce grand là et finalement
il se dérobe on l'a pas lâché on a
pendant une semaine on a campé devant
ses bureaux et à la fin finalement on a
obtenu notre premier 500 francs et
c'était pour nous le premier salaire
qu'on a eu à l'époque et on était fier
de ça et la plupart d'entre nous on a
pris la moitié on a donné à nos parents
et ça c'est la découverte du travail et
ça ça vous lâche plus vous avez une
sorte de conviction vous allez vous en
sortir par le travail quand j'étais plus
jeune j'étais vraiment quelqu'un de qui
avait beaucoup d'énergie et souvent
parfois dans les sorties on prenait pas
forcément et du coup quand j'avais
sentiments un peu d'injustice dans ma
tête du musée bon là on prend pas en
considération on fait pas confiance bah
le jour où je vais réussir à grandir bah
je vais quand je vais grandir je vais
réussir à faire quelque chose je sais
pas quoi mais je vais réussir à faire
quelque chose alors racontez-nous
comment sont nés les déterminer les
déterminer si on est
pour expliquer ce que c'est c'est un
programme d'accompagnement qui est
gratuit à travers toute la France on
propose des un accompagnement une
formation pour pour celles et ceux qui
veulent entreprendre leur projet c'est
un programme pendant 6 mois où on va on
leur apporte tous les outils et à la fin
il crée les entreprises où ils vont
retourner vers un poids et derrière ça
en fait quand je vous créez les
déterminer je me rends compte que moi
déjà à 20 ans j'avais créé ma première
boîte j'ai réussi à
me débrouiller comme j'ai pu et
finalement dans l'informatique dans le
Télécom et à cette époque là je
rencontre plein de difficultés le fait
d'être pas accompagné le fait de manquer
un peu de réseau le fait de pas avoir
des moyens financiers et quelques années
plus tard après un voyage aux États-Unis
je vois que l'entrepreneuriat et
l'économie peut être un levier puissant
d'inclusion pour tous et du coup c'est
là où je me dis il faut c'est important
de socialement d'aider les quartiers
mais il faut aussi les aider via le
développement économique par
l'entrepreneuriat par la formation par
l'emploi aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui
partenaire vous avez les élus vous avez
les entreprises
que vous avez aussi les collectivités
locales comment on en arrive là comment
on en arrive à pouvoir proposer des
formations financées ces formations aux
jeunes des quartiers qui vous a aidé
c'est tout le projet aujourd'hui moi on
a eu la chance de rencontrer des bonnes
personnes des chefs d'entreprise des
partenaires de grands groupes on a
énormément de partenaires on a BPI
France on a BNP Paribas on a Mazar on a
le groupe engie on a beaucoup on a
réussi à embarquer énormément
d'entreprises à nos côtés pourquoi
c'était important pour moi quand de
lancer un projet déterminé de pas le
faire en silo l'idée c'était de
mobiliser tous les acteurs de
l'entrepreneuriat du monde économique
autour de ce projet pourquoi parce que
la finalité on allait accompagner des
hommes et des femmes qui avaient besoin
d'un soutien qui avait besoin d'un
mentor qui avait besoin d'une expertise
que nous on n'avait pas au départ et
cette force cette énergie moi mon mon
obsession c'est de créer des ponts c'est
de créer des passerelles personne à lui
seul à la solution si on arrive à mettre
autour de la table du pouvoir public
je crois que vous avez rencontré
Emmanuel Macron qui vous a décoré c'est
ça
j'ai réussi lors de National du Mérite
j'ai pas encore fait la cérémonie je
devrais la faire
avec tout le monde que ça soit
Renaissance tous les partis politiques
on a besoin aussi à un moment donné que
nos sujets sont pas politiques nos
sujets sont à un moment donné
il concerne tout le monde les sujets
d'inégalités pour des jeunes
de mobilité sociale tous ces sujets si
aujourd'hui on reste dans notre coin
avec qui on va trouver des solutions
donc moi ma mission c'est de mettre tout
le monde autour de la table sur nos
sujets trouver des solutions de
convaincre parfois d'être pas d'accord
je suis pas d'accord avec tout ce que
les débats politiques mais faire de la
politique politicienne j'ai pas c'est
pas mon envie mais aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est politique dans les banlieues
vous dites faut pas s'arrêter à ça mais
aujourd'hui surtout pas aujourd'hui
je veux dire que ce livre il s'adresse
pas qu'à l'avant lui stress à toutes
celles et ceux qui se sentent bloqués
par quelque chose à tous ceux qui
parfois n'ont l'impression qu'ils ne
peuvent pas réussir dans notre société
ce livre il est là pour donner la force
il est là pour donner l'envie et
aujourd'hui au-delà de la banlieue on
sait qu'il y a des problématiques
partout et comment on arrive à régler
ses problématiques et c'est ce qu'on
appelle à faire et ce livre il est là
pour aussi démontrer tout ça déterminer
au singulier c'est vous moussakaara mais
il y a beaucoup de déterminés au pluriel
derrière vous et d'ailleurs on peut
retrouver dans ce livre beaucoup de
parcours de témoignages d'expérience de
tous ceux qui ont choisi la voix de
l'entreprise c'est-à-dire auprès de la
cité allez c'est l'heure grand temps
d'accueillir les affranchis pour leur
parti pris ils vont vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite le duo le
duo du vendredi Perrier d'Harry grand
qu'on retrouve avec plaisir Mariette
d'Harry grand pour son mot de la semaine
et l'avocat Bertrand Perrier pour son
billet d'humeur d'actu bienvenue à tous
les deux on va commencer avec un nouveau
rendez-vous action planète tous les
vendredis désormais dans cette émission
un parti sur l'écologie parti pris
signée Léa Falco bonsoir à vous vous
êtes membre du collectif pour un réveil
écologique et pour cette première
chronique vous vouliez revenir sur les
effets dramatiques du réchauffement
climatique sur certains travailleurs
dans notre pays effectivement dans les
dernières semaines on a 5 personnes qui
sont décédées pendant les vendanges
alors qu'on avait une vague de chaleur
inhabituelle pour la saison mais qui va
être amené à se répéter et donc la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
adapte nos conditions de travail non
seulement pour les métiers évidemment en
première ligne manuelle et qui se
déroule en extérieur mais aussi pour les
travaux de bureau en tout la DARES qui
est la direction du ministère du Travail
qui s'occupe des statistiques estiment
qu'il y a environ 10 millions de
personnes qui au quotidien sont embêtés
par la chaleur dans leur condition de
travail alors qu'est-ce qui permet de
protéger ces personnes ces travailleurs
c'est là que le bât blesse en France
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui dans le
code du travail de température maximale
au-delà de laquelle les salariés
pourraient choisir de ne plus travailler
c'est à dire exercer un droit de retrait
pourtant ça existe nos voisins et
notamment en Belgique et en Espagne et
c'est une des revendications du syndicat
européen des travailleurs alors une
proposition de loi allant dans sens
avait été proposé en juillet par des
députés elle est fille mais le ministre
du Travail Olivier du socle l'avait jugé
comme fausse bonne idée en raison des
multiples cas qui existent dommage parce
que ça permet non seulement de ne pas
mettre en sécurité des travailleurs à
partir de 33 degrés l'inseine estime que
la température devient dangereuse pour
les travailleurs mais en plus n'est même
pas spécialement intéressant pour
l'économie puisque d'après l'organisme
international du travail à partir de 33
34 degrés la productivité est réduite de
moitié alors la question à un million
d'euros c'est comment on s'adapte à ces
hausse de température la grosse question
dans les travaux manuels et d'extérieur
on peut d'abord envisager tout d'abord
des périodes pendant lesquelles on ne
travaille pas soit dans la journée en
proposant des horaires décalés soit dans
l'année par exemple pour les métiers du
BTP de plus en plus de mal à travailler
l'été et dans les bureaux il y a
évidemment l'adaptation nécessaire aussi
technique d'abord par exemple en faisant
en sorte que les rénovations thermiques
des bâtiments prennent en compte le
confort d'été mais aussi culturel parce
que dans les bureaux dans beaucoup de
bureaux aujourd'hui il y a des dress
code qui à cause de tabous sociaux
empêche le changement culturel et donc
par exemple les shorts pour les hommes
ou les chaussures ouvertes souvenez-vous
l'été l'hiver dernier quand nos
ministres avaient mis des cols rouler
pour défendre la sobriété on les attend
donc l'été prochain en chemisette et
sans cravates et surtout les plateaux de
France il faudrait peut-être couper la
climatisation pour voir comment
s'habiller c'est des corseter face au
réchauffement climatique merci beaucoup
merci Léa Falcon enchaîne avec vous
Bertrand vous vouliez revenir sur
l'arrestation du collégien soupçonné de
harcèlement lundi après-midi au collège
Henri Barbusse d'Alfortville dans le
Val-de-Marne oui c'est elle est très
vite le matin même des parents d'élèves
une lycéenne de seconde scolarisée dans
la même ville avait saisi le proviseur
et la police de messages extrêmement
violent reçu par leur fille pendant le
week-end je l'ai dit parce que je
voudrais que ce soit concret le
harcèlement c'est quelque chose de
concret et les mots on leur force
suicide-toi sale travelo j'ai une
haine envers ta race casse-toi va mourir
évidemment une main courante est déposée
et l'auteur des messages est identifié
et effectivement interpeller
l'après-midi même alors ce qui a créé la
polémique choqué certains c'est la
méthode employée puisque cette
arrestation dans la salle de classe en
plein cours a été fait sous les yeux des
autres élèves marine tondeuillier la
secrétaire nationale des des vers à
qualifier les policiers de Walker Texas
Ranger oui alors ce que je veux dire
d'abord c'est que ça n'est pas
juridiquement interdit l'intervention de
policiers dans une salle de classe et
encadrée par un certain nombre de
protocoles et si le chef d'établissement
donne son accord ça n'est pas interdit
c'est inhabituel mais ça n'est pas
illégal c'est pas interdit est-ce que
c'était opportun alors j'entends bien ce
que dit marine tondeuillier moi j'ai du
mal à être choqué pour tout vous dire on
nous dit que les enfants ont été
traumatisés par cette intervention
policière en salle de classe j'ai le
sentiment que des enfants de 14 ans
aujourd'hui ont été traumatisés par bien
plus d'image bien plus choquantes et
bien plus grave que ce monotage qui au
demeurant a été fait sans incident et il
me semble qu'il y a presque une sorte de
logique à ce que cette interpellation
ait lieu en classe c'est en classe que
c'est harceleur nuisent c'est en classe
qui joue les caïdes il y a donc une
sorte de logique à ce que ce soit en
classe qu'il soit interpeller
précisément sous les yeux de leur
victime ou de leur potentiel victime ce
qu'on devrait appeler des camarades de
classe mais je suis pas sûr que le mot
camarade soit très juste mais en tout
cas les autres élèves savent maintenant
que ce qu'il subisse le harcèlement ou
ce qu'il pourrait subir et non seulement
illégal mais effectivement puni par la
loi et par les forces de l'ordre et à
ceux qui objectent que la police n'a pas
sa place dans une salle de classe moi je
veux dire qu'on était ce qui n'a pas sa
place dans une salle de classe c'est le
harcèlement et que si la police doit
intervenir pour y mettre un terme et ben
c'est bien parce que ça montre que
concrètement il y a des effets on subit
les conséquences il n'y a pas d'impunité
pour les harceleurs et si c'est
interpellation a eu cet effet
d'électrochoc et bien tant mieux et elle
aura passé à la fois le message
répressif et éducatif selon les
harceleurs voilà ce qui s'appelle un
parti pris merci beaucoup Bertrand
Perrier vous êtes d'accord avec ça la
méthode parfois elle est justifiée quand
on quand on est face à ce fléau là le
harcèlement déjà je pense que le
harcèlement c'est un fléau qui qui de
plus en plus fréquent et ça a toujours
existé dans les écoles et parfois ça
peut venir nos enfants sans le savoir ou
ça peut être nos enfants qui sont
harcelés donc c'est un c'est quelque
chose à régler après l'intervention des
forces de l'ordre dans une salle de donc
là je pense que ça pouvait aussi
attendre à la sortie on peut sortir le
le le le gamin l'interpeller
tranquillement en dehors de l'école
parce que l'école c'est quand même on
parle depuis tout à l'heure l'école un
sanctuaire là c'est ce qu'a dit mais en
même temps l'éducation nationale je
pense que c'est c'est il faut il faut
vraiment traiter le problème de
l'harcèlement dans le fond c'est c'est
une priorité c'est un combat de tous on
peut plus laisser nos enfants aller dans
les écoles et et subir un harcèlement
donc c'est un sujet alors comment on le
règle je pense que il y a aussi il faut
punir les harceleurs ça on est tous
d'accord là-dessus mais en même temps il
faut aussi faire de la pédagogie
intervenir dans les écoles parler avec
les jeunes pourquoi on arrive dans une
société on est obligé d'humilier l'autre
pourquoi il faut comprendre aussi c'est
pratique
on va faire un pont avec ce mot de la
semaine c'est un néologisme en fait
Mariette darrigan vous avez choisi de
nous parler de
l'immigrationnisme ou
exactement alors c'est un néologisme
dans ce sens qu'il n'est pas au centre
de la du discours politique au
médiatique si on veut il a déjà été
entendu du côté d'Éric Zemmour du RN et
je voulais m'arrêter sur lui Myriam
parce que je pense que justement cette
rentrée c'est un petit nouveau là mais
qui va éclairer l'année et pour pour une
raison que je vais essayer de
d'expliquer
et d'abord parce que il a l'air
sympathique en fait c'est une façon de
renouveler le discours sur l'immigration
en lui mettant un suffixe on va faire un
peu de grammaire le suffixe East en
réalité est insuffis très positif par
exemple si quelqu'un aime les mots
croisés ça va devenir un cruciverbiste
si quelqu'un aime un peintre cubiste il
aime les cubes enfin ce que je veux dire
c'est que ça innocente en quelque sorte
là la position c'est comme si c'était
une opinion alors pourtant
immigrationniste
c'est clairement négatif c'est un mot
qui accuse c'est un mot qui accuse et
qui permet de positionner soi-même
contre ceux que l'on accuse alors dans
la langue politique classique par
exemple qu'on est marxiste avec Marx on
est gaulliste avec de Gaulle il y a des
grands modèles ou des cordes doctrines
aujourd'hui on en est plus tellement là
on peut être mélenchoniste on peut être
macroniste on peut être le pénis mais
c'est plus sur des corps de doctrine
c'est plutôt sur des gens sur des
incarnations et finalement il y a une
espèce de consensus mou entre toutes ces
personnes là qui seraient d'accord
aujourd'hui qui serait pour plus
d'inflation moins de moins de pouvoir
d'achat enfin il y a un consensus nous
donc les professionnels de la politique
sont obligés de refaire des histes ou
des histes pour repolariser et je pense
qu'immigrationniste c'est ça le projet
c'est à dire de refaire du pour contre
et du presque une polarisation une sorte
de gauche droite une sorte d'option
qu'on choisit une option qu'on choisit
et donc ça va structurer le champ
politique c'est ça que je voudrais dire
en cette période de rentrée c'est à dire
que là on va être devant une année très
politique avec les ADN en ligne de mire
et pour moi la vraie question c'est le
rôle de ce mot qui n'est pas notionnel
qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre derrière pas
grand chose mais en revanche il est
fonctionnel c'est ce que les
grammairiens appellent un mot outil donc
si je file la métaphore c'est pas un mot
qui va nous apprendre des choses sur
l'immigration se caler comment il faut
faire personne ne sait très bien mais
c'est un mot qui va essayer de
structurer les débats publics donc le
mot outil vous met dans un camp quoi
nous met dans un camp et si je file la
métaphore je dirais qu'il va faire de la
bricole idéologique mais qu'il risque de
charpenter nos débats donc c'est ça que
je voulais pointer en ce début d'année
merci beaucoup la création de néologisme
qui sont autant de d'armes politiques
dans ce débat c'est explosif de
l'immigration on s'arrête là merci à
vous les affranchis Merci à VOUS Moussa
Camara je rappelle le titre de votre
livre déterminé comment on s'en sort au
presse de la cité c'est le weekend
profitez bien on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine très belle soirée